[Musique]
merci bonjour jimmy bonjour à toutes et
à tous et bonjour olivier jean denis
bonjour monsieur biya trinquart urgent
et bonjour à tout le monde
vous êtes conseiller municipal du
lorrain en charge des délégations
suivantes insertion et jeunesse
démocratie participative et et culture
et vous êtes également conseiller
communautaire à cap nord avec vous on va
parler ce matin d'économie d'énergie et
de développement durable
concernant principalement
essentiellement la ville du lorrain mais
ça peut être étendu à l'ensemble du nord
voire l'ensemble du territoire de l'île
de la martinique alors pourquoi parce
que la ville du lorrain a signé une
convention là il ya quelques jours
c'était en fin d'année dernière je crois
la ville de laurens signé une convention
pour l'installation et l'exploitation de
centrales photovoltaïques sur l'ensemble
des bâtiments communaux
voilà alors ça ça s'inscrit dans une
démarche globale
dites-vous innovante qui allie
développement durable formation
économies budgétaires
alors parlez nous de ce contrat et
pourquoi surtout le conseil municipal a
voulu y aller
ben en fait la ville du loret en fait
engagé depuis plusieurs années dans
l'amélioration des conditions de vie de
la population mais surtout en respectant
justement leu leu en travaillant sur le
développement durable est donc dans un
premier temps nous avons réalisé sur les
deux ou trois dernières années le
remplacement des menuiseries des
bâtiments publics mais également des
l'éclairage intérieur donc en mettant du
led d'une led
au lieu d'avoir les bonnes vieilles
ampoules
aujourd'hui et après la signature de la
convention 2020 donc en décembre 2020
comme vous l'avez voilà bien nous
passons à un autre niveau pour être
précis parce que bon ce serait on va pas
rentrer dans les détails techniques dont
c'est une convention d'occupation
temporaire
mais surtout parlons été signé avec une
société privée donc synergétique d'un
dom tom
exactement c'est une convention que nous
avons signée avec cette société après
avoir lancé un appel à projets portant a
souligné olivier jean denis c'est une
première en martinique
c'est une séance assez jamais fait à ma
connaissance était en tout cas cette
échelle là n'ont en effet on est bien
d'accord il est et loch la ville a lancé
donc au début de l'année dès le premier
trimestre 2009
un appel à projets cette structure ont
répondu et si la société synergétique
dom tom qui a été retenu justement pour
passer convention avec la ville et
permettre justement la ville de mettre à
disposition tous les bâtiments publics
pour supporter des panneaux
photovoltaïques donc on y vient à
l'aspect un peu plus concret donc à
partir de cette année en fait le
chantier va démarrer la en bilan dans
quelques semaines
mais ce qui est prévu c'est qu'au bout
35 structures et bâtiments communaux aux
lorrains seront équipés de panneaux
photovoltaïques ses fans
voilà qui permettront d'avoir de
l'énergie solaire par le soleil la
chaleur du soleil c'est cela 35
sculptures 29 bâtiments publics et qui
vont en décolle mais les marchés
couverts bibliothèque et c'était
exactement et qui vont plus bénéficié
d'une rénovation de la toiture avant
qu'on puisse que la société puisse poser
les panneaux photovoltaïques et six
autres structures nouvelles qui vont
venir justement dans l'effort collectif
bain et mètres de là alors comme on va
dire ça on va réaliser un préau pour une
école on va réaliser donc en gare mais
aussi pour quatre aires de jeu on va
pouvoir faire l'accord il s'agit parce
que d'installer les panneaux
photovoltaïques à partir de ce chantier
de ces travaux il ya aussi de la
rénovation et la rénovation il ya les à
la rénovation de l'existant et puis à la
création de nouvelles structures dont
clés qui vont supporter des panneaux
photovoltaïques tout ce qu'ils ont ils
m² au total vont être mises à
disposition de la société justement pour
poser les panneaux photovoltaïques et
produire de l'électricité propre
treize mille mètres carrés alors sacré
chantier
donc ça commence cette année à partir de
quand vous annoncez 2021 mais ce que
c'est en fait on est on est en train de
finaliser les choses donc je pense que
d'ici deux ou trois semaines on va
pouvoir démarrer les premiers chantiers
les premiers chantiers première
rénovation pour accueillir les premiers
panneaux voilà alors abbas à un coup ça
comme ça représente un investissement
pour la laverie du lorrain kiki bon qui
a peut-être des finances pas trop
déséquilibrée 20 qui comme la plupart
des communes de la martinique c'est ce
que je n'ai pas la situation des
collectivités de martin et dites-nous de
l'investissement millions d'euros
d'investissement deux millions et demi
d'euros 2 millions et demi d'euros
d'investissements ce sera progressif
évidemment et ça va nous permettre sur
20 ans pour les bâtiments existants et
sur trente ans pour les six structures
nouvelles qui seront installés en fait
d'amortir le et d'avoir un retour sur
investissement en moyenne 98 mille euros
qui vont rentrer dans les caisses de la
ville chaque année
ah oui oui quand même alors ça c'est
intéressant sur 20 ans
voilà donc ces temps c'est une opération
équilibrée voire même bénéficiaire au
bout du compte c'est ce que vous vous
prévoyez s'avoue totalement c'est une
table et son opération bénéficiaire
parce que on aura un retour régulier sur
investissement donc à chaque
anniversaire signature de la convention
de la signature de la convention
2 on va pouvoir améliorer le quotidien
des del haut-rhinois parce que ben il y
aura de l'électricité un peu partout 3
sur les écoles les cinq écoles de la
ville on vient on va placer les écoles
en auto consommation ça dure ça veut
dire que l'électricité qui sera produite
à partir de photovoltaïque sera utilisée
immédiatement dans les écoles donc ça
réduira immédiatement la facture
d'électricité est globalement sur le
territoire c'est 70 % de consommation en
moins ça change
oui vous avez même le site edf
oui vous vous avancez maman chiffre à
vous avez mesuré alors
à ce que ça donnera mais enfin vous dis
non
après faut voir sur wii parce que bon on
est d'accord
voilà mais vous dites que donc ça
permettrait de faire baisser la facture
d'énergie de la commune du lorrain de
près de 3800 euros par an avec ses
panneaux avec ses panneaux
photovoltaïques exactement à améliorer
l'éclairage public baisser la facture
d'électricité de la consommation revente
de l'électricité à edf a récupéré donc
que dans le cadre de la convention et du
bail passé avec cette société récupérer
en moyenne 98 mille euros pas donc on
gagne à tous les niveaux mais on ne sait
pas on va pas s'arrêter simplement cela
on parle pour 20 ans évidemment mais il
y a à côté de cela un autre projet tout
aussi intéressant qui concerne
l'éclairage public les 1300 milles 268
points lumineux de la ville seront
remplacés les points lumineux sont à la
plage allogènes aujourd'hui eh bien ce
sera remplacé par odile aide mais en
allant un peu plus loin avec commande à
distance ça veut dire qu'on pourra
augmenter l'intensité ou diminuer
l'intensité module est modulé en
fonction alors il ya déjà quelques
communes qui ont commencé en martinique
qui ont déjà installés mais enfin c'est
à signaler le lorrain 6 mai en plus de
ces panneaux photovoltaïques
c'est que effectivement les ampoules led
par exemple au carbet il ya déjà eu une
première installation d'un certain
nombre d'équipements
dites moi le donc les champs le chantier
enfin l'installation doit durer sûr
parce qu'on a dit que ça commence là
dans quelques semaines sur 18 mois de
chantier examinera le chantier chantier
hockey des travaux alors tout ça se fait
aussi dans une volonté en tout cas s'est
présenté ainsi de commande directe de
participation citoyenne de démocratie
participative
vous dites que les administrés des lots
rhinois et le rhinoise seront de
véritables partenaires de ce
développement et pourront participer à
l'effort environnemental ainsi impulsé
oui et c'était vraiment pourquoi
exactement cela en fait on a prévu une
petite cagnotte donc un fonds
participatif pour la population
permettra à tout un chacun de se dire
ben voila moi j'achète une part de cela
de cet effort collectif et en
contrepartie 5 % de rémunération minimum
sera reversée à chaque individu pour
l'achat des deux c'est ce qu'on appelle
du cros funding ça participe 9,6 fois la
participation financière collectif voilà
donc on participe à l'effort collectif
et on bénéficie effectivement on a un
retour sur investissement puisque 5 %
par année c'est beaucoup plus que
d'accord aujourd'hui à la mode donc
utiliser ça vous proposer ça aux
haut-rhinois il part d'un investissement
soir on n'est pas obligé d'en passer par
là oui s'il n'y a pas d'obligation a pas
d'obligation et ce n'est pas réservé
uniquement aux laurines wasilla d'autre
part il ya d'autres partis nick heys qui
veulent participer à un bal et pourront
le faire mais c'est une volonté en fait
de la ville de daleh dans ce champ là
oui alors on va terminer sur peut-être
aussi une façon de montrer un bon
exemple un a priori pour l'ensemble de
l'île pour le reste de l'île alors une
autre action qui est lié à ce
partenariat cette installation donc de
plusieurs équipements photovoltaïques
aux lorrains une formation une
sensibilisation aux énergies
renouvelables pour les élus laurie noah
mais là encore aussi pour les usagers
pour les élus pour les techniciens de la
ville pour les techniciens de la ville
les usagers et les écoles parce que là
aussi on veut des primaires jusqu'à
jusqu'au lycée puisqu'on a un lycée sur
notre territoire et un collège
eh bien on veut accompagner la dynamique
accompagnée d'autres là toute la
population est formée tout le monde
justement aux énergies non renouvelables
d'accord on va on va conclure olivier
jean de nous il est donc on le rappelle
conseiller municipal du lorrain vous
nous parler de ce chantier qui va
démarrer dans quelques semaines
d'installation
35,1 structures qui seront équipés de
deux panneaux photovoltaïques voilà mais
vous êtes aussi conseillé à cap nord la
communauté d'agglomération du pays nord
est-ce que ça à vocation ce qui se passe
là ce qui va se passer aux lorrains à
s'étendre à d'autres communes voisines
au nord d'une manière générale nord
atlantique mais pourquoi pas aussi leur
carrière et puis voilà pour la
martinique déjà le territoire cap nord
c'est ses dix-huit communes aura
rassemblé 18 communes sur l'ensemble du
nord de la martinique et donc il y à des
espaces de démocratie justement entre
les élus déjà le bureau communautaire la
ville du loret et leur présenter au
bureau communautaire mais il y à aussi
la conférence des maires qui est
organisé par cap nord est qui est un
espace où les merdes pourront échanger
donc je pense que le maire du lorrain et
je le crois fortement que le mien d'une
photographie oui voilà faut pouvoir
faire un partage d'expériences et de et
de 8,2 vous y participerez aussi en tant
que conseiller communautaire du nord au
cap nord je pense que le maire oui on se
dit voilà et le mindu loin pourra le
faire effectivement auprès de ses
collègues de merde là du nord voilà très
bien voilà donc nous avons parlé de ce
contrat de performance énergétique dit
me voilà ça se passe aux lorrains les
premiers coups de alors peut-être pas de
pioche
les premiers coups doute y vont de
marteau voilà vont commencer voilà donc
premières communes de martinique à
proposer une telle démarche à sa
population
voilà et donc on le rappelle le
modification de l'éclairage public
réduction de la consommation électrique
d'éclairage de près de 70%
voilà
merci d'être venus nous en parler des
conditions de vie et l'amélioration des
conditions de vie puisque vous êtes en
charge de la délégation effectivement
insertion jeunesse démocratie
participative et culture bonne journée à
toutes et à tous merci perdues - 15 jan
[Musique]